- That sequence, that
sequence is really freaky.
We introduced this
character, this dinosaur,
called a pyrorapter.
- [Kelly] And I didn't
know what it was gonna do.
- [Chris] Right?
- And then I was like, what?
- At first you're like, aw, uh.
- A lot of people have said
like, you read and some,
maybe comments online and
people talk about like
why has Jurassic never
had a feathered dinosaur?
Because you know, all
birds are descendants
of raptors and dinosaurs, so, you know,
dinosaurs had feathers and
they didn't put feathers
and that's not real.
- They sound just like that.
- That's right.
- He's not bitter at all about it.
- That's if that's you, I'm sorry.
But I'm making fun of you.
I think this is kind of
like an Easter egg for folks
who'd always wanted a feathered dinosaur.
So there's this beautiful
red feathered dinosaur.
It looks like Thanksgiving gone wrong.
It's called a pyroraptor.
And the thing is freaking terrifying.
- Looks like a terrifying chicken.
- [Chris] Yes, that's right.
- Yeah, like a giant,
mutated terrifying chicken.
That also swims
- That also swims, yeah.
- That's the part where I
was like, I'm sorry, what?
I was like, what?
- [Bryce] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So that sequence is really,
really awesome and terrifying.
- And then you think,
'cause there's this part
where at one point in the
film, it's like, they go back,
like someone goes back for someone else,
and I'm like what would you do
in that moment in real life?
If like, it's let's say a grizzly bear,
like someone's back there and you're like,
we probably aren't both gonna make it,
so maybe it's your turn
to go, like I don't know.
- Thank you.
(Bryce laughing)